i you can please tell people that it was
a fair fight and see what the job
see what the jury and judge think tell
the world johnny
tell them johnny depp i joined up man
i'm
i'm a conceivable design and i you know
it's a fair fight
seems how many people believe or side
with you
today's topic johnny depp so if you
aren't aware recently johnny depp
lost his libel suit that he was uh
basically prosecuting well he's going up
against the sun
which is a newspaper in the united
kingdom and basically said that they
defamed him
that the things that they were alleging
in their articles about him were
false and a lie and so he was suing them
when the decision came back the judge
said that there was enough
merit to their claims and so therefore
the case was rejected and he ruled in
favor of the sun
so in the uk it's actually pretty
atypical
generally they favor public figures
versus the newspapers
uh so this is actually quite a big
victory for the sun but we're not going
to talk too much about the court case
only because we don't know what was
provided at the depositions we don't
know
what was alleged and what kind of proof
they provided so we can't really speak
on that
but following the decision made there
johnny depp was fired from uh the
three more movies that were being made
within the series called magical beasts
they already made the first two there's
three more left
and so he was fired from that and
they're gonna recast his role he will be
losing a lot other roles
uh within hollywood basically he's being
blacklisted but
pretty much um if you aren't aware
johnny depp has been accused of being a
wife
and there's been quite a lot alleged by
his
now former wife amber heard the girl
from aquaman
so that's i think the gist of it what
are your thoughts what do you think
am i surprised no what's funny is
the amount of crickets that we hear
quality
quality quality but when this
happens crickets they were very loud to
be able to say that
you know he needs to be this needs to be
that proof has been
shown it's not true i'm not the one who
throws
pots and there's a difference that's
different
that's different that's one does not
negate the other
just because i've thrown pots and pans
does not mean that you
come and knock on the door i'm not gonna
get into the details of that fight
you and i both know that you split when
there is no physical principle
and that you do it and meet like at the
very beginning of fights these days
you do it and you get dressed you are
screaming at me
i'm not going to validate my actions
last night
and from then we hear you've heard
crickets
you don't hear anything your
apology needs to be as loud as your
disrespect your rectification needs to
be as loud as your disrespect
oh he's a white beater he doesn't
nothing very bad no i'm talking in
toronto
i'm not start screaming until you poke
an animal enough it is eventually it
doesn't matter how friendly it is
you punch me in the thing and you see in
the face
and i watched you lie and then i punch
you and by the way you
i'm sorry that i didn't um punch you
across the face but i was hitting you it
was not punching you babe
you're not punched don't tell me what it
feels like to be punched i'm not hit i'm
sorry i hit you like this
but i did not punch you i did not deck
you
i was hitting you i don't know what the
promotion of my actual
hand was but you're fine she's been
marching and marcia's claiming to be the
victim when it was shown that she was
actually the perpetrator and then
nothing not a single word
nothing by doing so you're being
complicit in what you're trying to
denounce
you don't you already know what i'm
talking about
but i'm not disappointed i'm not
surprised i'm not i know this what
happened like that is double standard to
happen on both sides but whatever
this happens now and there's nothing to
be said so
i mean people have people asked us to
cover this and to be able to say
something about this
what haven't we said already
yeah i have to let the things follow its
course and and see how this is going to
go once this is going to happen
but at the end of the day the livelihood
of a man is it's
losing a career basically being a raise
off of everything being blacklisted and
stuff like that
and more and more people are just going
after it i mean amber also has
her contracts with l'oreal and other
brands and stuff like that
they're still they're not even talking
about recasting her for aquaman anymore
you know
they're thinking about pursuing the
movie with her in there knowing what
happened
seeing the evidence that we have but
it's okay
i mean at the end of the day we should
believe her after all to be honest with
you abba like it's like i see this
i'm so just discouraged with this i'm so
discouraged with this
because nobody really wants to hear it
nobody really wants to understand it
nobody when you talk about it you just
get
yeah people don't want to hear you so
it's just like
i don't want to talk about it anymore i
don't really want to like it's because
it's like it's not even worth it and
stuff
you want to talk about it you want to
have a conversation with it and people
don't
really want to have a conversation uh
i've heard some
i've tried to have conversation with
some of the people i'm like man man man
oh here you go crying oh boohoo who was
like what
really that that's that's the language
i'm trying to have a conversation so we
can understand this and then what's
going on
and that's what you're saying look at
you crying
it's just one man it's just us all the
information that i see that's all the
people that i see
when i try to that's the arguments that
i see whenever i try to point out this
the the the it's the inconsistency about
this thing
and it's hard to discuss it's hard to
you know just have a conversation
because basically i believe
i'm really one of the believers that you
know having a conversation is the best
way that we're going to be able to solve
all these problems that we have but no
don't have
don't want to have a conversation so
what do you want me to say
it's not my personal perception i don't
feel like everyone's
not interested or don't really care i
feel like it's quite the opposite i
think most people do care and they
side with johnny depp i think
advertisers media don't
but they're not necessarily a reflection
of reality the same way
you know politicians think that the
world solutions are this and then
they're really just behind the times
oftentimes the people are way ahead on
the curb and i think most people see
that she's a manipulative one or she can
be the abusive one in this situation
um some people say that you know he was
equally finding her it's potentially
true
um my question is not which one has more
culpability my question is not which
one's more guilty or not
it's hard to know when you're not there
what i do have an issue with is that
there seems to be one set of rules for
men and a different set of rules for
women
if you had made this an anonymous thing
you didn't know who the two individuals
were
i told you what they did i didn't tell
you what their gender was
how would you be able to tell them apart
amber heard is literally on tape
admitting to the fact that she lopped
off a piece of his finger
exactly because you're a bit you're
bigger and you're stronger so when i say
that i thought you could kill me that
doesn't mean you count her
you also uh that you lost your own
finger
she admits to throwing things at him
pots pans faces all this stuff glass
just because i've thrown pots and pans
does not mean that you'd
come and knock on the door she admits to
punching him hitting him
i'm sorry that i didn't um punch you
across the face but i was hitting you it
was not punching you
but you're not punched all forms of
basically beating on them right what are
they gonna believe they
have evidence of her admitting that she
instigated and that he tried to walk
away a lot of the times and that she
didn't like that she called him a punk
and
tried to emasculate him when he wouldn't
want to engage in conflicts with her
i'm not going to get into the details of
that fight you and i both know that you
split when there is no physical
principle and that you do it and meet
like at the very beginning of fights
these days
every single time you get dressed and
you split the top of a fight you never
can try and work it out
never fight for me you never come to me
you never self-calm you never self-suit
you are never the one to throw the olive
branch i'm sick and tired of it it needs
to change
but every time you don't like what i say
and you
run away will never work out anything
you can't run away every fight
you can't it's easy it's it's not brave
it's not strong
it's harder to say to somebody i want to
work this out i want to face what i have
i want to face what you have
i want to work it out with you you're
not working it out you don't fight
for me you don't fight when there's a
problem you don't come to me
you don't uh make peace with me you
never extend an olive branch you're
never the bigger guy you're
never the one that's like okay i'm gonna
put my own feelings aside for a second
and say
this is bigger than us let's stop
fighting you never are the one to come
and knock on my door
this is not hearsay this is not my
opinion this is her words
out of her mouth but because it's her
it ain't a thing but if it was him
now we got a problem and i think that's
the frustrating spark and i think it
speaks to the fact
it speaks to the idea that women are
just not held accountable
for the violence that they inflict on
people and the role that they play
in perpetuating certain cycles
there's no doubt that men and their will
in this
is quite more deadly oftentimes and more
pervasive
but i also have to say
what message are we sending to people in
regards to the idea of violence
if we say this man needs to lose
everything when he does it but when she
does it
let's just keep supporting her because
she's a victim in all this what are we
saying to
men who are the victims of violence that
basically their needs
their problems are going to remain
unheard and nobody cares and i think
that's a frightening message to
uh put out there so it's just
it's just one of those things that is
frustrating
um and you've
i don't know if i'm necessarily like one
of those people who's like man johnny
that's super interesting
but you know listen to those tapes just
from personal opinion i can't clarify
this and
tell you with certainty so this is just
hearsay uh but just listening to those
tapes in the
field that i got was uh based off the
interaction the conferences that she had
she would not accept any of the
responsibility for the things that she
did
she wanted him to accept all of it and
even as he was saying this is what you
did to me she found ways to gaslight him
and make him believe he was crazy she
would say stuff like oh i'm a
115 pound woman like if i punch you it
doesn't mean anything you're a man
do you believe you use me physically
do i physically believe i'm do i believe
i physically abused you
yes
do you know i'm 115 well not anymore but
i was 115.
like oh so she thinks that her acts of
violence aren't real
and she gets up on in front of you know
hundreds of people thousands of people
at a
at a woman's march and makes a speech
about how she's a victim she's been
suffering i'm like
what do you think that just because
you're shorter that you can't inflict
pain on people and
i don't know it's just you hear all this
stuff
and it just reinforces and this is
something i've i've hated most of my
life this kind of
entitlement and comfort that um some
women feel with crossing boundaries you
know
there's this idea that if a woman's
walking down streets she should be able
to walk unaccosted that her boundaries
her physical space matters
but i think with men you can hit us you
can punch us you can do whatever you
want and it's just not that deep i mean
i remember in high school
and watching a girl slap a dude in front
of everyone in class and the teacher's
like all right everyone take your seats
i'm like bro
you heard that smack halfway across the
school and you don't say anything
reverse the genders and who's getting
suspended but that was like a microcosm
for me and it made me understand
the way society structures violence and
and culpability
and the reality is we just don't make
people responsible for a lot of the
actions that they take based off of
their racial background um you know
their looks
their gender and it's just unfair when
we talk about equality we never want to
talk about
how about the advantages that the
perceived
disadvantaged group has okay we don't
want to talk about the fact that
black folks can get away with certain
things right that white folks can get
away we will
we'll talk about all the white things
white folks can get away with and trust
me there are things
but the black things that black
you was like people no this is a reality
and me pointing it out does not mean i
hate this group it just means like
that's not [ __ ] up
and that's your privilege you know
a woman can go in a club soccer dude in
the face
nobody does anything and if the dude
retaliates
half as much the whole club is coming
down on him like bombs over back then
what are you talking about women don't
have privilege you know it's not a
privilege to be a woman what are you
talking about abba
no this is uh this is a binary thing
there's the privilege and there's
unprivileged there's no nuance of course
now
what are you talking about and that's
what what do you mean 50 shades of grey
yeah 50 shades of black and white that's
what i'm saying it's
the conversation i've been having with
people so when i'm saying yeah i've seen
the social media and i've seen people
being
behind johnny depp but when i have this
conversation with
with who i believe
i should have the conversation with
because if i if i have the conversation
with people that believe
what i believe what's the good in that
right
the people that believe what i believe
and they already believe what i believe
i'm preaching to the choir
doesn't matter but if i believe but they
they
it's it's no use to it it's really no
use
they don't see it they don't have that
conversation with them you know i mean
like
you know what you mean how are we
supposed to progress then how are we
supposed to you're not
you're not you're not here to change the
minds of everybody true you're right you
know what i mean i don't make this
content for people who vehemently
disagree with everything and can't want
to hear my opinion
i make the content for people who are
open-minded
i want to hear different opinions my
error you know
i'm not going to go to a clan member
like discuss why black people should
exist
i'm like i'm going to discuss the other
people who may have an uncle who said a
lot of things
when they were growing up and maybe
they're more open-minded they want to
see the world right so
i don't stress myself with people who
are too close by that's that's that's
going to be a thing forever
uh but i think there's a lot of people
who are just wanting to hear different
opinions and so
yeah and i think also hollywood's
response you know stealing a man's bread
money that's you know men
yeah that's something you got to worry
about careful it just reinforces the
idea like who cares what hollywood
thinks
you know like they have no more they
have no sense of morality
so you're gonna tell me that you know
hollywood the
the birthplace of hebstein's and
weinstein's are going to tell me how
to morally act and how to think they're
going to dictate what i should and
should not do
you shouldn't go with slayton yeah yeah
all the people
yeah all right yeah just just seeing how
outspoken everyone was when she was you
know supposedly being hurt but then when
he turns out to be
what he's saying you know it's just
people got to protect our bread so
to me this is just more of the same it's
just a reflection of how our society
views
violence against dudes it's very common
and um
just a broader discussion about that i'm
not surprised
i don't think he has any chance with
this case because the truth is he did
engage in some forms of
lying some people say it's retaliation
some people say self-defense but
i wasn't there you weren't there we have
no way of truly knowing you believe it
maybe because you want to or maybe
because you feel like some of the
evidence suggests he's stronger but
there's enough stuff there to say that
he potentially did engage in quite some
stuff so
there's no libel or defamation if
there's
quite a bit of truth to your claims so
um we'll see how the court case goes
like i said none of us
know what kind of evidence they have but
looking at it from my perspective
he's gonna lose he's gonna keep losing
and um
yeah that's just the truth it's not what
you guys wanna hear but
seems to be what's gonna happen so yeah
that's all i got anything else you want
to add
it's 20 20. that's the year of taking
your out i'm gonna leave
yeah that's it
leave your comments below we wanna hear
what you guys think
[Music]
me